Good morning, everyone, and welcome to the
Big Data to Knowledge: A Guide to the Fundamentals
of Data
Science.
I'm Jack Van Horn from the University of Southern
California based here at the BD2K Training
Coordinating Center, and I'd like to welcome
all of you to our second volume, if you will,
in our series of data
science seminars focused on the fundamentals
of data science.
And we are very excited to be beginning this
season with a lecture by Jonathan Entwistle
from IBM, talking about collaborative and
scalable open source data
science.
And just a few words about Jonathan.
Jonathan has worked in the federal government
data science community
for over a decade working with large programs
within the NIH, within the Food and Drug Administration,
as well as
CMS, and he holds a master's degree in predictive
analytics from Northwestern University.
He specializes in data
science at scale-leveraging technology such
as Hadoop and Spark.
He lives in Maryland with his family.
And, so I
understand, he routinely discusses data science
at dinner with his statistician wife and his
2-year-old son.
So it's
good that he's helping the next generation
of young scientists in data science.
So without further delay, I'd like to invite
Jonathan to give his presentation and invite
you to send in any questions
that you have via the little chat feature
that you can see in the go-to webinar panel.
I will go and try to select
various questions to ask Jonathan at the end,
and I'm sure Jonathan will pass on his contact
information and be
available for questions and comments offline
at any time that you want to reach out to
him.
Again, just one final
thing, is that this year, we're going to be
having a series of these lectures.
We're going to be trying to do them
regularly on Fridays at this time.
We're going to try and steer around the holidays.
And so you may find, at least initially, where
things are
interrupted by holidays.
We understand those are important family times
and times when you'll all be away.
But
then, certainly, things will pick up steam.
And then we also ask you, if you have any
ideas for speakers for our
seminar series, to please reach out to us
and make those suggestions.
We'd love to have them.
Without further
delay, let me have Jonathan take it over.
We're excited to hear from you, Jonathan.
Thank you.
Good afternoon to everyone on the East Coast,
and good morning to those of you joining me
from the West
Coast.
Again, my name's Jonathan Entwistle, and you
saw my contact information up there.
I actually do primarily
work with the US Federal Government, including
all of HHS, but I've got a lot of experience
spanning all kinds of
different spectrums.
So if there's folks on who want to talk about
cybersecurity or other things like that, I'm
happy
to do so.
The agenda for this presentation is really
going to focus on a health care use case with
some real data.
And you'll
be able to follow along with me, if you're
so inclined, by going to datascience.IBM.com,
and you'll be invited to join
what's called the Data Science Experience.
I highly recommend doing so, so you can move
along interactively with
me, if you want.
Although, obviously, you don't have to.
So for those of you on the phone who are already
seasoned data scientists, I have to walk a
fine line.
You might
find a little bit of the stuff at the beginning
a little rudimentary.
But for those of you who are not data scientists,
I
think this is going to be a good use of your
time.
It should be very easy to understand what
we're trying to do.
I'll
try to explain how things work.
I won't go into too much detail on specifics
of code or anything like that.
But as
pointed out before, you can always feel free
to reach out to me after the fact.
So without further ado, I think we'll move
forward.
Now, one of the major things that data science
tries to do is
automate the processes that we do every day.
And so one of the things that I'd like to
do is try to help us predict
breast cancer.
So I've got my data science console up here,
and you guys should be able to see that.
And what
I'm going to do is head over to the community,
and I'm going to look up the data set.
And that data set is a breast
cancer data set that comes from the University
of California, Irvine.
Let's just put it in here.
And I'll let you take a
quick look at it.
What you'll see is that in this data set,
you've got a patient identifier.
You've got a diagnosis of either benign or
malignant tumors.
And then we've taken structured data that
we've gathered from the X-ray.
Now, some of you
might be thinking, well, data science on highly
structured data is easy.
Teach a computer how to recognize it from
a picture of an X-ray-- and that's what I'll
be talking about in the second portion of
this-- deep learning and
convolutional networks, those types of things.
But to set a baseline, what I really wanted
to do is see if I could teach a computer to
recognize breast cancer the
same way a doctor would by looking at an X-ray.
So you can see, we've got about 32 columns.
We've got a few
hundred examples.
And these columns, other than the diagnosis,
are details that we've taken from the X-ray.
For
example, if we see a malignant tumor, what's
the texture of that tumor?
What's the perimeter around it?
How
much area does it take up?
So highly structured data so far.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to create
a project for this.
I've called it NIH video.
Now, we are talking about
scalable data science.
So everything I'm doing here, you'll notice,
is written in either Python or R. And I create
notebooks.
Now, if you're not familiar with notebooks,
IBM thinks that they are going to be absolutely
the sort of
standard for how we share analytics and code.
And what's interesting about a notebook, as
you can see here, a
notebook looks a lot like a Word document.
This particular notebook is a Jupyter Notebook,
which, again, supports Python, R, Sparks,
Scala, those types of
languages.
And what's interesting about them is that
you actually can write code and execute code
and pull data
from these.
So we'll be working in a notebook environment
today.
I won't make it pretty for the sake of us
actually
getting to the data science part of it, but
if you are interested in taking a look at
what a professionally-authored
notebook with professional data is, you could
go take a look for, again, classifying tumors
with machine learning.
So one thing I want to do is exploratory data
analysis.
So what I've done is I've downloaded that
data set that I
pointed out earlier-- Breast Cancer Wisconsin
Data Set.
So you can do your exploratory data analysis
wherever
you want, but I'm going to just do it within
the Data Science Experience here.
I can also show you how you might
do it with things like PixieDust in Python.
But I want to generate some basic metrics
about things.
So first of all, we can see here that out
of our cases, 357 were benign, and 212 were
malignant, which means that
we've got a slight imbalance of data there.
That's probably something we'll need to take
into account.
And as we
look across the others, we don't see any kind
of a normal distribution.
We just see data, which is kind of data.
So if
we're trying to predict benign or malignant,
you've got a couple of different options.
You could go with-- an
example would be a logistic regression, which
is really good at deciding between two binary
things.
But because of our data and how it can be
sort of non-linear, non-parametric, we're
going to go with a tree-based
approach.
And I'll get into what that means later.
If we needed to visualize something, we could
do that here, but
what I'm going to do is create a notebook.
And I'm going to show you the steps you go
through to produce that
model, and then we'll move again to the deep
learning stuff.
So I'm going to create a new notebook.
And I'm doing
this deliberately a little bit slowly so that
if you are following along, you can do so.
I'm going to call this Predicting Breast Cancer.
I want to write in Python.
R works just as well, but what I want to
point out here is that everything we're doing
is running on Spark.
So underneath the covers, we're writing Python,
but it's executing as Pi Spark or SparkR.
And if you're not familiar with Spark, it's
incredibly important to the big
data space.
What Spark is is an engine which is in memory,
which is distributed, which is designed to
do a variety
of different topics.
So you could have Spark do machine learning.
You can do graph analytics with Spark.
You can do SQL-like
analytics.
But today, were primarily going to be using
Python to do machine learning [? models.
?] So the first
thing I'm going to do is pull in that data
set that I just got.
So I can do a header here.
We can say, this is my
notebook, and we're going to predict cancer.
Then add-- whoa-- add a new cell.
And we can get off to the races.
So what's interesting about these is each
of these can be individually executed.
So I need to pull in my data.
I'm
going to go over here to the data tab.
And everything that you see in blue here,
by the way, is sort of unique to the
Data Science Experience.
So there's some nice things up here around
data scheduling and collaboration, but
what I want to do is insert my data set that
I have in this project as a [INAUDIBLE] data
frame.
Now, by the way,
anybody that wants to get access to this project,
just send me an email, and I can add you as
a collaborator.
You'll
be able to see all the code, all the data,
and work with me on it as we [INAUDIBLE].
Now, this code actually generates [INAUDIBLE]
code, which is really slick, but at the same
time, it shows my
password to me.
Not to everybody else.
But since we're recording this, I'm going
to take a moment to pause the
screen, generate my code, and then I'll delete
it.
So I'm pausing the screen now.
Give me one moment please.
I'm
just making some adjustments to the code so
that we get a good data set.
And then, again, we'll be good to go.
OK, hold on.
By the way, if you're interested in, again,
following along, you can use-- let's see--
this beautiful notebook that I'm
about to put on the screen over here while
I'm generating my code.
Hm.
So I tell you what.
Let's actually walk
through doing this the old-fashioned way,
just so you can see it.
So what I'm going to do is take my breast
cancer
data set that you saw me download earlier--
I put it in here in my NIH video demo folder--
and I'm going to drag
and drop right onto my screen here.
You'll see I've uploaded it.
You'll see it appears down here.
There we go.
And I'm going to create that notebook
again.
So we're going to call this Predicting Cancer,
create the notebook, and then do the code
generation.
There
we go.
I'm going to run it.
And you can see, I have my data.
So, again, I've got my identifier, my diagnosis,
and then other data sets.
So how do we move forward?
Well, the
first thing I'm going to do is rename this
data file just to be something simple, because
I don't like typing that every
single time.
So we're just going to re-execute this.
All right.
Now we move into the phase of what's called
exploratory data analysis.
Now, I like to use a tool called PixieDust
to do this, which is a Python tool.
And to make
sure that we've got the proper libraries,
I'm going to install PixieDust here.
Here we go.
It looks like I'm good to go
on that front.
I'm going to tell my notebook that I want
to use PixieDust now that I've got it installed.
So I import,
and now I can use the display call.
So this is a function which actually generates
something similar to what you
might get with Excel or a tool that does charts
and graphs.
So I can say, I want to do a bar chart, and
I want to do it based on-- I don't know.
We could do the ID, and we can
do diagnosis here.
And so I can do some exploratory data analysis
in this way.
I can look at distributions, things
like that.
Now, we talked about this earlier.
I do have a slight imbalance between malignant
and benign.
So what
I'm going to start to do now is leverage Python
code to do a decision tree.
So we've analyzed our data here.
I'm going to show you that rows 200 through
210 look very similar.
Right?
And
then I'm going to have Python do some basic
pre-processing for me.
So if you haven't used Python for data
science, this is one of the most important
packages available, scikit-learn.
So when I run this, I'm going to go
ahead and do the install.
Hopefully, I've already got it installed.
Yes, I do.
Great.
And now I'm going to do what's called pre-processing.
So I'm calling that pre-processing function
from scikit-learn,
and I'm doing what's called a labelling code.
And if you look up here, you can see my diagnosis
is either malignant
or benign.
But to a computer, it's easier for systems
to understand if it's a one or a zero.
It's binary.
It's on, off.
So
it makes our processing faster, and it makes
it easier to use certain algorithms.
So the first thing I'm going to do is check
to see if any of my data is null, because
that can cause problems.
I'm
going to have to go back, impute data, that
type of thing.
Doesn't look like it.
That's great.
I'm lucky enough that
this is a demo and I can cheat a little bit.
I've got a nice, clean data set.
The last thing I'm going to do is, if I'm
going to change this data file [INAUDIBLE]
is the best practice, I like to create a new
one.
So I'm going to say that
my original data file is equal to this DS2,
just in case.
Then I run code to do the transition that
I talked about.
So we change that diagnosis field to a one
or a zero, and
then we do a describe.
So this gives us a statistical sample of what's
going on in this data, what percentages or
where.
You can see here my diagnosis is either one
or zero, but it might help me narrow down
things like
standard deviations [INAUDIBLE].
I don't see anything that scares me here,
so what I need to do now to create a
valid model is segregate out some of that
data.
So there are multiple schools of thought on
this, and we will test this later, but I'm
going to bring in a thing here
called train/test split.
And what this does is it takes all of my examples
and it segregates out 20% of them in this
case.
You can see down there, test size 0.2.
That 20% is set aside, and it's not used in
my building of my model.
So when I teach the computer how to recognize
breast cancer, 20% of it does not get taken
into account.
And that
way, I have a good way to test it later.
So I'm going to run this code here.
And you can see executes.
By the way, you know if it's executing, because
it's
got a little star over there.
So what we're going to do next is build a
decision tree.
And decision trees mimic human
reasoning.
They're very easy to understand.
And I think they're not quite as powerful
in some cases as some
tools, like deep learning tools, but they're
very quick and they're very easy.
So I need this to generate some
graphics here, and I'll just make sure that
I have that installed right.
And then I'm going to pull in the tree library.
So the tree library in Python implements what's
called a C4.5 decision tree.
And you can see here that I'm saying
don't use the column identifier, because the
identifier obviously is not relevant to if
they breast cancer or not.
And
I've given it the splitting columns.
So it's worth taking a moment to talk about
decision trees a little bit more, and
you'll see exactly what I mean in a second.
And the human, we can reason, for example,
how long is it going to
take me to get to work today?
Well you've got variables that go into that,
like, is it raining?
Is it Monday?
Do you
take me to get to work today?
Well you've got variables that go into that,
like, is it raining?
Is it Monday?
Do you
live in D.C.?
All of those affect an outcome.
Decision trees are a way for a computer, a
machine, that's been given an outcome, like
malignant or benign, to
figure out which of the features that you've
given it affect that outcome the most, and
then work backwards.
So
we're going to do this processing here.
I'm going to run this cell.
It's executed.
And now what I'm going to do is
export this to the graph, so you'll be able
to get a picture of the tree that it just
generated.
So you can see here,
this is exactly the tree.
There are many knobs to tweak when you do
decision trees, and we are going to spend
a little bit of time actually
going over a lot of those, but what you can
see is, when your concave points mean is greater
than or equal to
0.049 and the rest of these functions, we
can then determine if something is benign
or malignant.
So when new
data sets come in, when I get a new data set
that the system has never seen before, I can
simply walk the tree,
ask the question yes or no, and I can get
a result.
Really powerful stuff in terms of implementing
things like
business rules or being able to do multiclass
associations and classifications.
So this falls into the family of supervised
learning, because we are giving the computer
an outcome and telling it to
predict the outcome of a new thing.
And like I said, decision trees are great
because they're easy to understand.
They're very fast.
They don't need, necessarily, normal curves
and data or things like that, but we can make
it
better.
So for those of you who already know what
a decision tree is and how to tweak those,
this is where it gets
more interesting, I think, for you.
Let's interpret our tree.
So we know what all these points mean, generally
speaking, especially if you're a doctor, but
we need to evaluate the model.
Now, remember, we left out 20% of our data.
So what I'm going to do now is import that
20% and test it.
I'm going
to use to predict functionality here out of
scikit-learn metric to actually say, OK, so
for those 20% that we didn't put
in here, how good is this model?
And you can see the output right here.
So your accuracy is 92%.
You guessed
correct 92% of the time, or 93% if we're rounding
up.
AUC stands for area under the curve.
Area under the curve
has to do with a statistical method of judging
the success of a model, called receiver operating
characteristic.
But
for those who don't know what ROC curves are,
you can simply think of this is, 93% of the
time, we manage to
catch the malignant tumor.
Now, if you're like me and you want to know
if you have cancer, then 93% is pretty good,
but it's not great.
There's
still 7% that we missed, or misclassified.
You could build something like a confusion
matrix here to show false
positive, true positives.
That's easy to do.
But instead, what I'd like to do is try to
focus on improving this model.
So
this is our baseline here-- 92%, 93%, 94%.
That's pretty good, but it has its limitations.
So what I want to do is use
something called gradient boosting.
So I'm going to use this thing here called
XGBoost, which is another Python package,
and XGBoost has become
very popular in things like Kaggle competitions
because of how powerful it is in predicting
outcomes.
So we're
going to use the XGB classifier instead of
the traditional tree.
So I import that.
And don't worry about this
deprecation warning, but our version's back
a little bit.
So in order to improve this model, we're going
to use a
couple of different techniques.
We're going to tune the parameters of the
tree-- things like gamma, lambda, tree
depth, child weight, these types of things--
and we're also going to use k-fold cross-validation,
in this case, phi.
So to do that, I'm going to import cross-validation.
Now, the way cross-validation works is it's
a model used to
measure how well model generalizes in using
the training set, and it divides it into even
smaller training sets to
gauge how the model performs on data it hasn't
seen before.
So for example, if we had five samples-- we
can call
them A, B, C, D, E-- we take a model built
on A, B, C, D, leave out E, and score it.
Then I do the same thing for B,
C, D, and E and leave out A. I do this five
times.
And the reason I do this is because you could
build a perfect tree
if you used 100% of your data.
But every time you get a new data set, you
can't necessarily guess that correctly, because
you overfitted your
tree.
So just like a normal tree, sometimes these
types of trees need paring back.
They need to be told, don't be
so specific.
You need to be more general.
That way I can go ahead and-- when I get new
data in, I have a better
model.
So again, we're picking binary logistic here
because we're trying to pick whether it's
benign or malignant.
You can leave these-- we can get into a detailed
discussion about some of these later if we
need to, but I'm just
going to set those right now.
I'm going to do it [? three ?] times.
So I run this, and we're now good to go.
So what I'm going to do next is bring in
libraries to plot this out, as you'll see
here, and then I'm going to build a function.
And again, I'm not going to go
into the specifics of the code here, but what's
important here is that I've got a function
to evaluate the model.
It's
going to iterate over the data, and it's going
to try to increase our area under the curve
and iterate, and iterate,
and iterate until it can't get any better.
So when I run this piece here-- you'll see
it running in the background.
And we'll call the function.
So again, don't
use ID.
Call the function evaluate model.
Use the training data.
The features are what we've just described.
And
execute.
So you see here, it's running again and again,
and the area under the curve is going up,
and up, and up
significantly.
So what we figured out here is that by using
k-fold cross-validation, we're doing what's
called
boosting the tree.
We're using multiple trees in an ensemble
to get a better result.
So now we're doing pretty well.
We've got a list of which features are most
important.
Right?
These are the things
that a doctor would look at first to determine
if something is benign or not.
And we've got a much better accuracy
and area under the curve, but I think we can
even do better.
And this is where the art of data science
comes in.
I
often joke with my wife that it should be
called data art instead of data science.
So we're going to do a couple of
things here to do what's called tune the max
depths and the child weight.
So the max depths of the three is how
many nodes can I have?
And again, you don't want a tree that's super
complicated that overfits to a data set.
So we want to figure out what
our max depth should be, and we want to figure
out, when-- if there is something like this
texture mean-- and
clearly, it's off the charts in terms of importance
in predicting cancer-- that its importance
doesn't make the others
less important, because there may be fringe
cases where the radius worst or the concave
points mean is far more
important than the texture mean, fringe cases,
these types of things.
So this is where the turning part comes in.
So in order to do this, I'm going to go ahead
and build another function here, where here's
our default model, but
we use a thing called grid search CV.
So it's cross-validating again.
It's going to run, and it's going to find
that the
model that works best at the max depth of
five and the minimum child weight of two.
Now, I made a mistake here,
which is always good during the live demo.
I forgot to import grid search CV, so I need
to go ahead and make
sure that I include from scikit-learn.
Move that up.
Run that.
And now we shouldn't have a problem.
You can see
it's executing, and it will produce results
in a moment.
Now, another piece of the puzzle is something
called gamma.
So gamma increases-- or, sorry, makes the
algorithm more conservative, which means it's
less prone, again, to overfitting.
You'll see here, by the way, that it
went down, up to six, and then back down to
five, and then determined that child weight.
So the way we're doing
the scoring is that area under the curve still.
So that's good.
Now we have another variable which we can
add to
our study.
To evaluate the gamma and the lambda, we're
going to use this code here.
So we're using our same evaluate
model.
We're including that max death and child weight,
which we just figured out from up here, and
we're going
to execute that to see-- oh, excuse me, I
forgot a piece of code here.
Let's not forget to figure out what the
gamma should be.
Here we go.
Here's how we figure out the gamma.
So again, we're doing a test.
And to do this,
we're iterating over the data.
Now, once you get to very large data sets,
making sure that you're using a scalable technology
underneath the
covers, like Spark, is really important.
Because as we evaluate models, we need to
test different models.
We need
to test different parameters.
And there are going to be fringe use cases
where the computer may see something
that we don't.
So what we determined here is the ideal gamma.
You can see that there.
We're going to set the
gamma in our original classifier.
And we're going to retest now.
See how we're doing.
I would argue that we're
probably, hopefully, doing better.
Yeah, so we're getting some really good results
now.
We're talking about 99%, 98% accurate, similar
features,
importance.
That could be expected.
So there are more sampling parameters.
And I've got a limited amount of
time on the call, so I'm going to put the
code here so you can go check it out later.
If you have access to Data
Science Experience, you'll be able to see
this easily in the sample models there.
But I'll run this.
You'll get an
output.
Here's lambda and alpha.
Again we're adding tuning parameters by using
a very sort of regular scientific
process where we execute, test, execute, test.
And again, it takes a little bit of time to
process, even when running in Spark.
One of the nice things about Data
Science Experience is that this is all free.
Everything you're seeing today is free, including
the storage and the
execution.
But I can scale that up and down.
So if I have a very large data set, instead
of using two cores like I am
on this, I can scale it to 300 cores or whatever
I need.
So that's kind of helpful.
So we'll let these run.
And then
finally, we'll run our final model, because
now we have a good idea exactly what to use
for alpha, gamma, the
child weight, the depths, the number of estimators,
and the learning rate.
How do you think we're going to do?
Pretty good?
I hope so.
So we'll run this.
And here is going to be our final
prediction.
Bring in the data, use this, and spit out
the answer.
So I think what we'll have at the end of this
is a
model which effectively is 99.9999% accurate,
which is pretty good.
If I'm a doctor, I think that's a pretty good
rate
for me identifying stuff or not missing stuff,
especially malignant cancers.
So we're much better than we were.
That's the original.
Right?
98%.
And here's where we are right now-- 0.99999.
So pretty solid stuff there.
To recap what we did is we got our data set,
which you see there.
We made sure we had library.
We did some
basic exploratory data analysis.
For the purposes of a demo, this is usually
where you spend a lot more of your
time, but we're not going to do that today.
We did some basic statistical descriptions,
and then we started down a
path of the tree.
So we created a basic tree.
We validated that that approach works, which
is great.
And then we
actually went and created a more advanced
tree by taking advantage of a ensemble model,
a boosted tree.
We used the code to actually regenerate all
of the different parameters to that function,
and then we iterated over
that to increase the score for all of the
different parameters that we think are worthwhile.
So we started out with a
pretty good result, and we're going to end
up with a great result.
Now, there are some of you who are thinking,
I
don't know Python.
I don't ever want to do this.
Well, we can do it automatically, too.
I'll take just 30 seconds to do
this.
But you can see here, I've got the same data
set.
If I go over here to analytic assets and tell
the system to create
a new model, I can do that as well.
Now, we'll just call this new model.
And you can find this type of technology in
a lot of modern examples of tooling, like
SPSS Modeler or SaaS or those types of things,
but effectively what we're
doing here is what I call auto modeling.
So I take in a data set.
It figures out the hyperparameter optimization,
model selection, and then it gives me whichever
one scores the best.
So this would be for somebody who doesn't
ever want to touch a keyboard, doesn't want
to go near Python.
You
still have the option to be able to do predictive
analytics.
So in this case, select the column that you
want to
predict-- diagnosis.
I want to use all the columns, so binary classification,
and I want to do four different models
here that we can train.
So in the background, the system here is doing
everything that I just did manually, and it's
going to do it presumably pretty quickly.
But there are options.
I view this as, you could give something like
this to a doctor.
They could evaluate if any of the models work.
And
then there's a handoff to a seasoned data
scientist, who's going to go ahead and run
that code that you just saw.
So what it's doing in the background here
is it's going to actually train and evaluate
all these different models, do
the same types of things that we just did
in Spark, and actually spit out performance.
And you'll actually see which
ones work best.
We use the decision tree classifier, and here
it's only getting it to about 92% for the
AOC.
We were able to do better as human beings,
and I think that makes us feel pretty good
about ourself.
And so last,
but not least, we'll let it do its gradient
boosted tree.
And turns out here that random forest might
actually be a
really good way to go.
So random forest is a great technology for
decision trees where you're building sort
of
multiple decision trees on each other.
So we do have a model now where we can actually
deploy this and send
data to it.
Anyway.
So we've talked now about predicting breast
cancer, and we've done it using highly-structured
data.
And
I mentioned before, some might say that that's
cheating.
How do we do this against unstructured data?
Well,
there's a quote out there, which I like a
lot, which is, "In machine learning, having
more data is almost more
important than having better algorithms."
So I don't have images of breast cancer lying
around.
I could probably
go find some.
But what we're going to do here is, just to
show the basics, is show how a different variety
of
machine learning-- something called deep learning--
can be trained to recognize handwritten digits.
This is a
classic example.
But if you haven't seen it before, it can
be very effective.
One thing to note here is that deep learning
is significantly more computationally intensive,
usually, than traditional
machine learning.
So I'm not going to run this one interactively.
But you can see the results from previous
run.
So what is deep learning compared to the machine
learning and the tree based learning that
we just talked about?
Well, deep learning tries to simulate how
a human brain works, and it has-- the original
ones were called neural
networks, just like we have neurons.
So it tries to make its own connections and
then it builds what's called the
hidden layers, so a deep learning model can
have hundreds of layers.
And it will assume or try to think about a
problem the same way a human thinks about
a problem, by connecting
ideas, testing it out, seeing what works.
If it doesn't work, it goes on and creates
a new hidden model.
Now that's a
very rudimentary explanation of deep learning.
I'm happy to go into some of the math after
this or maybe during a
different session, but that's sort of what
you need to know for now.
And an important part about deep learning
is that we figured out that things like graphics
processing units, GPUs,
the same thing that runs video games, is actually
really good at doing matrix math, and deep
learning tends to
involve a lot of matrix math.
So at IBM, we are talking about big data here.
When you need to do deep learning
against large amounts of data or large streams
of data, you have to use GPUs.
So that's why cars that are coming
out now that are learning to do image detection
and find other cars and people on the road
are using GPUs
onboard.
So enough about deep learning for the moment.
Let's take a look at what we're going to do
here.
So I've got data
that I borrowed from Google of handwritten
digits.
So there's a large database of these handwritten
And it's
easy for a human to understand what makes
a 7 a 7, but it's actually very difficult
for a computer to read a picture
and understand what's in it.
This is, admittedly, a simplistic example,
because you could have-- a different
example might be, show me pictures of birds,
or showing me pictures of cancer, on a lung
x-ray.
But with that, you're going to have multiple
different angles.
You can have different locations for the cancer.
So it's
not as simple, it's not black and white, and
we'll talk a little bit about that more later.
Anyway.
What I'm going to do
here it install a package called nolearn.
And nolearn is a Python package that does
deep learning.
In fact, we're
going to be using something called a deep
belief network, and people belief networks
are pretty quick to execute
against simplistic datasets like this one.
So we're using it here.
But we can talk about other algorithms as
well.
So as I step through this, I've got my [INAUDIBLE]
learn which is the same thing I had for my
previous example,
where I need to separate out test and training.
You'll find that's a common theme throughout
all of data science.
I've got metrics, so how does it do datasets,
so sample datasets.
This is the deep belief network, DBN, and
then
some Python map and other image stuff.
We're going to pull in data from TensorFlow,
and this is where we're pulling our images
and our labels.
So for
every image or the handwritten number 9 is
a label that tells the computer that this
is a 9.
It's worth mentioning
TensorFlow because there are a lot of libraries
out there put out by different companies and
different open source
groups, things like Keras, TensorFlow, Cafe,
Torch.
These are all names that are really powerful
engines that are helping people sort of do
things like machine vision
and that kind of thing, but it's a little
bit difficult at the moment to work with all
of them at once, because there's no
real standard for that.
It's sort of the wild West.
So that's something that IBM is spending a
lot of time on, is
making sure that if people want to use these
things, they all work together and they all
work together in a similar
fashion.
So in the data science experience here, we
have technologies like TensorFlow built right
in, so you can use them
and you can execute on GPUs and things like
that.
So right here I'm separating out my training
and tests, just as
we did before.
As you can see here, I'm leaving out 33%,
not 20%.
So I've got a database of about 37,000 or
so
images used for training, and then another
36,000 or so for testing.
So that's pretty good.
All right, so now we need to train the pattern
recognition model.
If you want to get into the very sophisticated
math
that goes into some of this stuff, I can highly
recommend you go to this link.
There's a bunch of data there on how
we do this.
But effectively, what we're doing here is
we're telling the deep belief network solver,
which is the CDN
call here, that it can go 300 layers deep,
as we've figured out that we think that that's
around the most optimal, for
each of the 10 digits.
And that's that 10 [? epochs ?] here.
So this part takes a while if you run it on
your own, especially if you don't have GPUs
to accelerate it.
But each of
these represents the 300 layers for each digit.
So it goes through all 10 digits, and if you
were at the point where
you were trying to do something extremely
difficult to recognize, like very small cancers
in x-rays that require
sophisticated technicians to read, this is
where you would probably stray away from a
deep belief network and
move toward something like a convolutional
neural network.
And convolutional networks are better able
to take into account the entire picture, and
better able to layer different
angles, different versions of what the thing's
looking for, because a cancerous tumor looks
completely different
from the side than it might from the front.
My wife is spending a lot of time on this
actually right now doing some
work for the Transportation Security Administration,
where they're trying to automate the process
of detecting
people walking through x-ray machines and
hiding metal or other weapons in their clothes
in their body.
So really
application's across the board on this one.
Some good stuff there.
And what's interesting about this now is my
report.
So I call dvn.predict against the training
data.
And you can see
here my precision and recall is great.
So I've built a model where I've been able
to actually teach a computer to
read handwritten digits, and I've done it--
I don't know if you've seen-- but it's maybe
less than 100 lines of code,
because I'm able to take advantage of some
of these really sophisticated packages in
Python and [INAUDIBLE].
One of the interesting things, just as an
aside, about this space right now, is that
all of the really interesting stuff
that's happening in the open source.
This, I think, analytics is the shining example
of how open source can be the
most effective way to get data out there,
get code out there, and increase innovation.
So IBM a while back, even
though we have our own technologies like SBSF,
we're not abandoning it but we're certainly
embracing how the
accelerated process of open source is really
changing the world.
So we're very excited about that.
And that's one
of the reasons we built this data science
experience-- to make that process easier.
So I'm going to define a function here, where
I call it random image.
So it picks it out.
It picks a random image out
of my entire data set and tries to figure
out what it is.
And let's see how we do here.
So I know I ran this before,
and it occasionally does miss things.
But actual digit is 7, predicted a 7.
Pretty good.
We think it's a 5, definitely a
five.
Here's a tricky one-- what's that?
7?
It's a 7.
So we're 100% In this case.
Not bad, especially when they get a little
wonky like that.
I did not write this notebook.
Of course, the people who
do write it are all listed here.
So some of them are colleagues in academia,
industry, some of them are us.
But
here's an example.
Again, a very simple example of how we can
use deep learning to do image classification.
So
we have Watson for oncology, I'm sure some
of you have heard of this.
We've spent years working with things like
convolutional neural networks with Watson's
natural language
processing and all that, to get Watson, the
supercomputer, to be able to use this type
of thing in the background
and actually recognize cancer, and then tell
you what to do about it.
What are the best forms of treatment?
Those
types of things.
Now, we're making pretty good time here.
I think I've got a couple of minutes left,
so I'll highlight some other
technologies that I think are really fascinating
and that I'll leave 10 minute at the end for
questions.
So one of the
other most important things that I think we
have to really focus on is genomics.
I don't know if any of you are or in
the genomics field, but one of my favorite
packages is something called Adam.
So if you go out there and you look up Apache
Adam-- A-D-A-M-- you'll see that there is
actually an open source
distribution that runs in Spark, meaning highly
saveable, that's able to do certain genomic
staff.
Now, I am by no
means a geneticist here, but what I'll show
you here is something called counting k-mers,
K-M-E-R-S, something
that previously took, I don't know, a year
to do, we can now do divide and conquer, spread
across multiple ECs or
cloud systems, and produce tangible results.
So here's-- if I say a 10, where k is 10,
looking for strings of 10 and counting them,
and this is actually doing it get
out of a mouse's genome.
So this is something that's obviously not
as pretty as some of the other stuff you've
seen, but if things we're working on an IBM,
how do we work with the FDA to look at the
genetics of certain trends
or chemical formulas breaking down the new
drug safety type stuff.
So fascinating stuff there.
Again, that
technology, if I can give them a plug, is
called Adam, A-D-A-M, and if you're a geneticist
I highly recommend you
look into it.
Good stuff there.
And the last piece that I'll bring up is something
which may seem trivial, but it's actually
super important.
We all
work in environments where we have constrained
resources.
And so the other side of predictive analytics
is
something called prescriptive analytics.
If I can predict that I'm going to need a
certain amount of the drug or
anything like that, then I need to know what
to do about it next.
So this is something-- it's a classic computer
science problem called the nurse assignment
problem.
And here
we're combining Python with IBM's resource
optimization engine.
So I need to schedule all these nurses together,
I load in their data, and they each have specialties.
They each have vacation times.
They each have costs
associated with them.
Some of them are in different locations, some
of them don't like each other and don't work
with each other.
That's exactly what a prescriptive analytics
engine does.
If you give it data about what you're
trying to accomplish, and then you give it
resource constraints, and we find the most
optimal way to do that
scheduling, or to have the right drugs at
the right hospital at the right time based
on these types of things.
So a really important part of predictive analytics,
something which can be absolutely integrated
in with the open
source technologies like Python and R, and
then built out so that you can actually do
these prescriptions or
prescriptive analytics on the fly.
So putting the right vehicles in the right
place.
This is something that I've
personally spent a lot of time with, with
logistics, groups like the Army, Navy, that
kind of stuff.
So all that being said, I'm now at 12:50.
I'd like to invite my host to jump back on.
Hopefully not passed out.
[LAUGHTER] No sir, Jonathan.
I'm not.
Thank you so much for that really great tour
through the IBM data science
experience.
That was fascinating.
We have a question where one of our listeners
was asking about how the code
defines the feature importance score in your
decision tree.
Yeah, great question.
So let me go back to it for you here.
When you do things like decision trees, you
get feature
importance, because it does really one of
two things.
So this is something you can go and look up
later.
But it
either uses what's called a Gini index or
an entropy score.
And what it does is it determines what the
most
important part of that dataset is, because
it's able to split the data based on it.
So-- let me just bring up my model here--
part of that library is what we were talking
about, and I'll get down to the
exact spot.
But what it's realized here is that this concave
points mean, if it's greater than or equal
to this, you're
almost always in a certain category.
Another easy analog might be gender.
If you're trying of determine if
somebody is a male or a female, you could
use data like how much do they weigh, how
tall are they, but I think if
you just looked at their physiology, that
give you hands down the biggest clue.
Maybe not all the time.
But it's an example of feature importance
there would be, we're at the root node of
the tree, and it's figured out
that pretty much anything to the left or right
is going to have a huge impact on whether
in this case it's benign or
cancerous.
So let's see-- the actual code part that gives
you that output is right here.
So we're doing this part of
the algorithm, we're getting the score, of,
the feature score, and then sorting it by
how high that score is.
So 10,
obviously, in a descending.
Hopefully that answers the question.
I will put up my contact information.
So you can ping me if I didn't list it there.
But any other questions?
Yes, we do have a couple of other questions.
So Someone is asking, do you have any resources
on choosing the
right machine learning model for your particular
question?
Yeah, and this is where it gets that data
art piece as well.
So we have technologies that do automatic
modeling.
I
showed you one of them today.
We call that IBM machine learning.
And what that does is it separates out the
obvious technologies-- or, sorry, obvious
algorithms or models for a problem, if some
just aren't appropriate for
certain things.
And then it will go through and do subtle
testing.
We call it cognitive assistance for data science.
So there are other technology platforms out
there that do that.
If you want to do it the old fashioned way,
unfortunately, it's sort of an understanding
of the models, and this is where the art comes
in.
So you may
understand that Random Forest works really
great for certain problems, but you've got
more ability to tweak
algorithms or things there.
So a lot of it's going to be personal experience,
unfortunately.
But we do have
technologies like Watson Analytics and Watson
Machine Learning that will go through, test
a bunch of model, and
then give you what it thinks is the strongest
solution.
So that's technology that's been out for a
while.
But again, a
lot of it can be just based on personal experience,
unfortunately.
Right.
Do you see a lot of people interested in these
sorts of solutions who are working in the
area of clinical trials,
or in drug discovery, for example?
Absolutely.
So we do a ton with clinical trials, clinical
informatics.
The drug discovery stuff I'm not as strong
on, but
we do do it there.
When you think about it, the platform is a
highly scalable, inexpensive platform, where
you can
have it run either up in the cloud or on your
own site.
And that alone is kind of nice, because I
can take a data set,
and I don't have to pay a million dollars
to run it through a supercomputer.
And you have a huge amount of flexibility
and control by using this open source stuff,
because there are
algorithms that come out for clinical informatics
out of certain research institutions monthly.
Where I can go
download the latest and greatest on some paper
I just read.
So we're doing some of this at the VA right
now.
I
there are teams at the NIH working in sort
of small teams.
One of the problems with the industry right
now is it's
just a little immature.
It's a lot like sort of business intelligence
was back in the 90s, where everybody had their
own Excel spreadsheets
on their desktops.
So we're trying to help with that, get around
some of the governance problems, bring people
with together with repeatable data sets, and
be able to share the insights that they're
come up with.
Yeah, well that's fantastic.
And one of the things that you had mentioned
in a couple of times sort of in passing is--
everybody's kind of a little familiar with
the Watson supercomputing system, and I'm
curious if this has-- exactly
how this dovetails with that, or perhaps it
doesn't at all, but I thought maybe if you
could explain, if there was, that
would be very interesting.
Yeah, great-- great question.
So there's some core logic that Watson does
that helps us do things like
understanding language and intent and belief.
So what you saw today is what we call our
Watson data platform,
not that unstructured data isn't data.
But it focuses much more on structured data
and certainly on the open
source.
So we do use Watson within the Watson data
platform, but it's fundamentally different
than the Watson
that you see on TV that plays Jeopardy and
things like that.
That Watson is less about predicting the future
using math and more about interacting with
humans and
understanding written word.
So when you bring them together, you get these
nice interfaces where I can bring in a
structured data set and I can ask a question
in regular old English, and Watson will understand
that, translate it
into a mathematical equation, and then we'll
use some of these mathematical techniques
and open source
analytics on the back end to output the correct
answer.
So it's an exciting time to be at IBM.
It's interesting.
And of course, I can load my own data if I
wanted to, if it were-- I do work in neuroimaging,
for
example.
And if I had not necessarily the raw images
but I had measurements made on those images,
I presume I
could look this in as my own data source and
then carry on, right?
Absolutely.
So everything you saw today is available up
at datascience.ibm.com.
Doesn't cost anything.
There's
tons of tutorials, sample notebooks, sample
data sets used, you can load up your own stuff.
And the other thing I'll
put in there is that we have a website-- it
used to be called Big Data University, so
I think you get a sense of what
it is.
But we now called the Cognitive Class The
AI, and that's all free training on the big
data space.
So if that's of
interest to you, I'd say go check it out.
And we always appreciate feedback on that
too.
That's fantastic.
Let's see what time do we have here?
We only have like a couple of minutes left,
but I don't see
any other questions flying in.
But anyway, maybe I'll take this time to once
again thank Jonathan Entwistle from
IBM to give us a rundown of the data science
experience.
It looks like very useful, very well thought
out, very
flexible and scalable solution for dealing
with a lot of our biomedical data types, and
being able to document and
share that with others and other colleagues.
So it sounds very exciting.
I hope that those of you who are interested
will reach out to Jonathan with any
additional questions via his contact information.
Check things out at datascience.ibm.com or
cognitiveclass.ai and
learn more about it.
Once again, this is our fundamentals of data
science seminar series, and do watch for it
in
your emails for announcements about our further
sessions and our further speakers and information
about them.
And once again let me thank Jonathan for his
lecture this morning, and thank you for joining
us.
Thank you very
much, everyone, have a wonderful day.
Thank you much.